[Music]
josh is with us in columbia south
carolina hi josh welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you thank you very much for taking
my call sure what's up
so i'm 26 years old and i'm actually
about to start a new job in a new city
i've been living in apartments um for
the last three years i've been working
and i really like the lifestyle i'm not
really in a rush to be in a house but i
do know that i need to start thinking
about saving up for a down payment so
i'm trying to decide exactly how
aggressively i should be saving cash
versus investing into retirement
are you out of debt
yes sir okay fully funded
baby step three okay so you're there are
you investing yet yep
yes i've been um getting my full match
with my employer
also maxing my ross and um hsa
and that puts 15 decent head start
does that put you at 15. a little bit
over 15. okay i'd scale that back down
to 15 and then begin saving up cash for
that house and put that in a you know
high-yield savings account somewhere you
don't need to invest it unless this is
going to be you know five plus years out
but it sounds like you're wanting to get
in the house sooner than that what's
your game plan on getting in a house
what do you think
so i don't i'm single right now and i'm
not really interested in buying a home
uh you know before i'm married i do have
plans to get married in the next you
know 10 years or so
but like i said you know i'm really in
no rush um if i could guess right now
i'd say anywhere between
five and seven years i'd like to be
really thinking about being in a home
yeah i'm with george and i would lock it
in at 15 of your income into retirement
and i would start saving aggressively
above that
and just you know you just pile it up
for right now and let's just stack cash
because um it it doesn't sound like that
you have selected the young lady or she
has selected you yet
that's right that's accurate kind of a
vague concept at this point what's your
income
uh i'm at 110. awesome yeah so point
being that
um this could flip uh
this could this whole environment could
change rather quickly
uh right and that's kind of exactly my
thought going into it which is why part
of me wants to you know have a little
more than just my emergency fund in cash
but yeah yeah i would pile up as much
cash above your emergency fund above
your 15 going into retirement as you can
you can't really save too much cash
in that situation because um
you know you you've got it out there
somewhere in the future i'd like to be
married if i've met the right person and
so forth that's a good
good general sentiment but uh you know
when you meet the right person you might
be married a few months later that could
happen
and uh so uh you know by the next time i
talk to you this time next year you
could be married looking for a house i
don't know
uh that wouldn't be that unusual by the
way so i would set a specific goal and
not just make it i'm just gonna save up
money i would say i'm gonna aim to save
up twenty thousand dollars this year i'm
gonna say aim to save up twenty thousand
the next year five years i'll have a
hundred thousand dollars that helps you
have a game plan instead of just hoping
money gets saved exactly yeah you need
to have a set amount that you're going
for above the 15 and above the emergency
fund that's exactly what i would do